il est aux couleurs de la région et
apparaît sur certains produits
d'alimentation depuis sa création il ya
six mois ce logo promu par le conseil
régional est encore discret dans les
rayons on va retrouver sur cette
nouveauté le logo de la région et le
logo celle du centre en revanche si vous
prenez la traditionnelle chips et
packaging qui existe depuis longtemps
sur ce projet là on ne retrouve pas le
logo tout simplement parce qu'on tend
une que producteur il faut laisser le
temps au cid écouler ses anciens stocks
d'emballage du temps pour se mettre à la
page il en faut pour les producteurs
comme les consommateurs estime cet
épicier d'oliver selon lui la marque
manque encore de visibilité
aujourd'hui ça parle aux consommateurs
mais ça ne parle pas à tout le monde
nous en tant que distributeur également
beaucoup de produits régionaux
on n'a pas encore l'identité visuelle et
le marketing la plv qu'il faut magasin
pour vraiment mettre en avant mettre en
avant l' les produits de la région cd
des choses qui vont arriver très
rapidement si ce vigneron l'ensemble des
vins aoc est agréé par la marque
régionale lui ne veut pas d'étiquette
pour ses bouteilles ils comptent sur
l'effet bouche à oreille pour promouvoir
ce nouveau label
la formation où circule vite aujourd'hui
c'est vrai qu'on se rend pas compte mais
ça circule ça circule très très vite et
je pense qu'à un moment comme je visais
les gens voyaient dans les allées il ya
des brochures qui circulent avec le nom
des producteurs donc les gens vous voyez
dans ses brochures donc tout ça ça je
pense que ça contribue à développer la
développer la marque un développement de
la marque sur le long terme c'est ce que
vise le président du conseil régional
pour lui l'objectif de promotion du
territoire est déjà en marche et la
fierté d'un territoire il ya la fierté
d'une région qui est une région du
tourisme une région de la qualité de vie
une région du maraîchage une région avec
des arboriculteurs fruitiers merveilleux
une région de l'élevage on veut que tous
ces produits la rayonne
123 professionnels de l'alimentation ont
adhéré à la marque elle compte
aujourd'hui 1400 produit à gré